[Musique]
je m'appelle le rameau go j'ai très bien
et je suis auteur j'écris aller sur
l'esm d'assad
j'arrive à être un petit peu mais c'est
pas la principale raison pourquoi j'ai
écrit l'un d'eux sur qui on envoie il y
en a beaucoup dans les écoles et c'est
important d'en parler dans les un peu
partout dans mon livre c'est quand
quelqu'un dise des choses méchantes ou à
plusieurs reprises donc parfois ça se
fait verbalement physiquement ou parfois
c'est même sur internet
je sais pas pourquoi il y en a mais moi
je sais juste la règle et moi j'étais
juré qu'ils délivrent juste pour le
plaisir donc j'écrivais plusieurs sur
plusieurs sujets autre ancien manège
idéaliste s'appelait jeanne le renard et
moi et puis ce livre je voulais vraiment
amy est un peu dans le même genre que
celui que je suis c'est lui qui m'a
inspiré c'est fanny britt qui a écrit
ses livres
ça se passe dans une école et dans un
camp de vacances puis se fait intimider
j'étais vraiment très inspiré mais j'ai
tout recommencé à écrire mon livre
et puis le j'écrive à des intervalles
rythme très régulier parce que c'était
juste pour le plaisir
donc ça m'a pris un an l'écrire au
complet puis ensuite le j'ai fait les
démarches pour le publier
[Musique]
je les fais moi même la une après midi
j'ai décidé de j'en avais parlé à mes
parents en mal mais j'ai cherché des
maisons d'édition jeunesse puis je leur
ai envoyé mon manuscrit et puis c'est la
maison d'édition harper qui a décidé de
les publier
c'est une maison d'édition à risque
partagé donc eu en payer une partie mais
nous aussi donc on a fait une page
facebook avait pour refaire sociaux
financement
donc on après vente des livres puis
c'est comme ça qu'est on a financé notre
projet maintenant mon livre c'est emilie
c'est long de la personnage principal et
les temps 6e année et elle se fait
intimider par une fille qui s'appelle
patricia donc elle nous donne plein non
pas très gentil l'humilie elle est un
peu gênée elle dit parce qu'elle pensait
lui pas trop se faire remarquer donc là
elle va devoir travailler ce puits avoir
plus confiance en elle
puis à 20 khz intimidations de la bonne
façon
emilie elle est très créative elle
aimait créer un petit peu un peu comme
morale j'espère surtout que ceux qui
vont les riz vont comprendre qu'ils
peuvent agir comme contre l'intimidation
donc j'espère que c'est surtout ce qui
va apporter un beau message j'ai
toujours rêvé d'écrire un livre mais
aussi d'aider les autres donc le ca
fabien ruet faire les deux en même temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]